talk to me about war how does bitcoin
essentially prevent war because i
believe that that's what you say the u.s
war on terror was something like 80 000
per us household but it was all printed
if you showed up at someone's household
with a bill for 80 thousand dollars like
hey we're blowing up some people on the
other side of the world to preserve some
oil interest for me and my buddies i
need you to pay this bill that's why
people are going to put up a lot more
resistance right you can see it versus
just printing money and no one
understands it and everyone just feels
the pain and then when prices increase
right the actual tax is being inflicted
oh it's the greedy capitalist it's the
greedy food manufacturers why why the
cost of food is increasing they'll say
anything but debasing the currency so
they can obfuscate this behind people's
ignorance of money and i think over time
basically bitcoin just first of all
through what we're doing just talking
about this decentralized media and
educational effort i think people are
waking up to the realities